salut tout le monde nos profils draft
NBA 2023 continue avec ce podcast qui
sera dédié un joueur d'Arkansas et
Jordan Jordan Wolf
un joueur qu'on aime beaucoup chez
envergure et qui fait débat en ce qui
concerne son potentiel c'est parti
[Musique]
Jordan walk il est très jeune il a 19
ans né le 3 mars 2004 Dallas dans le
Texas 2 mètres sans chaussures
93 kg et une envergure de Maboul de
mettre 18 d'envergure mesurer au NBA
combine
je vous disais qu'il fait débat en gros
tous les classements de valeur américain
le classe au deuxième tour de leur
classement de valeur donc 39e chez
ispienne 40e pour Kevin O'Connor
shederinger 54e chez diatlétique et Sam
vessening mais nous envergure chez nous
ce 14 juin date de l'enregistrement pour
le moment il est toujours 24e peut-être
descendre a-t-il un peu on ne vous
expliquera peut-être pourquoi dans ce
podcast en tout cas les personnes
chargées de vous présenter Jordan Wolf
sont
Julien et Manu salut les gars salut les
gars salut Julien
donne-moi la petite biographie la petite
biographie qui va bien de ses débuts de
profil comme à chaque fois qui est
Jordan watch
originaire de Dallas
desotos c'est un quartier c'est une
commune de Dallas terrible de mortalité
les photos sur Google maps sont
terribles il était à family Academy
c'est une commune de Dallas aussi qui
est terriblement résidentiel et sèche
aussi comme tu peux t'en douter
[Musique]
il est tourné je donne juste les stats
au début excuse-moi il faut pas que je
fasse mais je me fais 18 points en ce
moment et 5 à 6 OK dans sa première High
School deuxième High School link Academy
beaucoup plus connue dans le Missouri
cette fois-ci on change carrément de
coin des États-Unis il fait son année
senior il a
grandir il a fait un comment dire
ce qu'il a fait lors de ce petit tournoi
son année senior 15,3 points de rebond
et 3,1 face ok j'insiste un peu ce sera
pour la suite après donc McDonald's
Jordan classique tout le monde a fait ça
parmi les
joueurs 5 étoiles donc recrues Arkansas
Paul biaccordy biancardy pardon je l'ai
écorché son enfant
spécialiste school chez spbn parle du
meilleur tout way player de 2023 il
faudra qu'on parle de ça aussi voilà
arrive Arkansas avec deux autres
processus 5 étoiles dont on a peut-être
parlé dans d'autres podcasts
bon année correct en plus d'accord bof
mais plein de choses à dire sur lui
et son parcours juste dernier au niveau
de familial
j'ai pas trouvé grand chose à part que
il est très suivi par son papa et
d'après une interview de Monsieur Barlot
voilà qui connaît son père il a l'air
d'adorer cette famille donc ça doit être
voilà et puis dernière chose au niveau
visuel il est atteint de Halo 6 alopéia
c'est une maladie auto-immune qui fait
qu'il n'a aucun
poil ou sur le nouveau Charlie villano
c'est un peu ça même position d'ailleurs
même si de mettre 0,93 kg et jouer 3 4
cette année en tout cas c'est ce que va
nous raconter Manu que faisait-il
qu'est-ce qu'on lui demande d'être faire
dans cette équipe d'Arkansas
donc c'est un joueur qui sortait du banc
quasiment toute la saison il est sorti
du banc voilà ça force principale
c'était de défendre et il a fait surtout
ça défendre sur les meilleurs joueurs
adverses quasiment que ce soit des
meneurs ou des ailiers des pivots voilà
de fait de son envergure qui immense tu
l'as un peu au début c'est voilà c'est
un gars qui peut tout qui peut défendre
tout le monde du moins au niveau initié
en attaque c'était un peu plus fade
parce qu'il était surtout contenté
cantonner au coin de des trois points tu
vas dans le corner et tu fais pas grand
chose d'autre
et du coup là il a été surtout sur du un
peu de catching shoot un peu de cut mais
franchement offensivement c'est très
très pauvre ce qu'il a montré cette
année et là c'est vraiment le le
contexte arkanza ce qui était vraiment
pas pour lui en fait très peu de
création très peu de spacing très peu de
shooter très peu de c'était vraiment pas
fou fou et du coup il a pas il a Julien
en parler justement sur le geiko moi je
l'avais la première fois que je le vois
c'est sur le gecko
ou c'est vraiment deux joueurs
différents c'est c'est très difficile de
le
[Musique]
mot
projeter sur sur la NBA donc moi je me
base beaucoup plus sur le sur le High
School finalement
que sur ce que j'ai vu à Arkansas ça me
donne une autre vision du joueur qui
peut être en fait
mais c'est
si tu grattes un peu plus c'est un
joueur qui peut faire juste Julien
pourquoi tu le drasterais toi on a
compris que tu l'adorais mais quand même
il a fait il c'est dur les les les gens
qu'on parle qu'on rien à qu'on rien
montrer offensivement leur année prêt de
race c'est dur j'ai projeté alors c'est
un énorme défenseur ça c'est clair
dans tous les sens du terme il est c'est
un athlète il a des mains énormes on a
parlé d'envergure il a des mains qui ont
l'air très gros
mensurations
moi je trouve qu'il est déjà fort mais
toi il est alors je suis fait une
distinction mais je sais pas si ça
existe vraiment je trouve qu'il a de la
force mais il est pas encore très
puissant tu vois on sent qu'il va
devenir encore plus puissant mais bon
quand il y a un mec qui lui tombe sur la
tête il bouge pas la façon dont il
arrive à attraper les ballons dans les
mains des joueurs ça ça demande de la
force et puis c'est drôle quoi c'est
drôle de le voir défendre en un contre
un ou tu as l'impression que un mur pour
l'attaquant adverse le kaluma de critton
il va s'en rappeler encore longtemps de
ce sont face à face c'était vraiment
drôle quoi et il a fait disparaître dans
le même match il fait disparaître tuer
Alexander comme si c'était comme si il
était un globules blancs tu vois ce que
je veux dire il a absorbé le gars avec
ses grands bras c'était incroyable donc
voilà après effectivement côté
côté attaque on a rien vu alors on va il
faut pas se répéter quoi on a déjà dit
tout ce que je voudrais dire
si je peux le faire c'est que il finit
quand même l'année à 34% à 3 points
je crois qu'il est sur les 19 derniers
matchs il a 11 sur 32
match il est plus à droite que c'est 28%
dégueulasses de l'année voilà alors
c'est des tout petits c'est des vraiment
des tout petits échantillons il est à
70% au lancer franc mais et en plus il a
pas du tout pu développer
son jeu de cône allez on va encore
utiliser ce mot de connecteur moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un gars qui sait
faire des passes qui s'est passé là-bas
à ses coéquipiers de façon sûre et et
dans le jeu alors ce qui joue pour lui
c'est quand même par exemple au tournoi
NCA
arkan ça sort une grosse perf et élimine
comme ça
et là il joue 33 minutes quoi
et en fait les matchs où il a joué le
plus c'était souvent des gros matchs en
fait on a l'impression que quand c'était
serré quand il quand il fallait quand il
fallait gagner bah il était sur le
terrain quoi même si c'était un trou
noir offensif alors après il perdent
quand tu es conne et là en fait face à
une équipe intelligente yucon il le
punit il le regarde même pas
offensivement et du coup
Arkansas n'arriverait à faire c'est un
peu ce qui risque de se passer en NBA
ce serait peut-être un joueur de playoff
quoi c'est quoi son plafond Manu c'est
quoi son meilleur scénario
pas forcément
de temps il peut jouer ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est un Bruce Brown est-ce
que c'est
un exemple quand il s'agit de le mec qui
défend et qui met derrière qui prennent
des bons et offensif et qui font les
seuls play
mais
lui lui fait doit être un petit peu plus
grand que que Bruce Brown mais en même
temps Bruce Brown maintenant il met ses
shoot quoi donc
et ce qui peut jouer dans la question si
vous êtes celle-là est-ce qu'il peut
jouer sans sans progresser au tir
s'il reste comme ça entre 30 et 35%
allez si on prend la fin de saison
moi j'ai du mal à le voir exister parce
que c'est
quelqu'un qui peut faire d'autres choses
mais il aura pas ce rôle là au NBA en
fait
quasiment meneur c'est un mec qui
portait la balle qui qui distribue le
jeu qui qui faisait le jeu de son équipe
je me rappelle d'un match au gecko il
sort 10 insistes
ça c'est un rôle qu'il aura plus jamais
en fait et si le chou devient pas
c'est compliqué et alors à quel point
à quel point parce que là je vous
demandais d'être précis dans la
latéralité dans l'anticipation dans le
le voilà la l'intensité le moteur à quel
point c'est un gros défenseur parce que
on peut s'acheter du temps de jeu NBA
quand on a un expert quand on est dans
le top 5% d'une spécialité quoi
5% de des joueurs NBA je parle donc on
parle vraiment du grand spécial et ce
qui peut être là-dedans
à terme je pense pourquoi
parce que c'est un scénario qui prend
beaucoup beaucoup d'espace de par ces
bras mais aussi les jambes il a la
latéralité pour moi elle a
l'impressionnante même s'il doit encore
apprendre c'est ce que j'ai créé sur le
gecko à l'époque il faut à l'époque
c'était un an ou en fait il faut qu'il
apprenne un peu à coordonner le
physiquement tu sens qu'il est un peu
comme si il continuait de grandir et
qu'il apprenait à vivre avec son corps
tu sens que des fois c'est un peu
bizarre qui qui fait déjà ce qu'ils sont
pas très naturels mais je pense qu'à
terme dans trois quatre ans cinq ans
c'est un mec qui va pouvoir défendre sur
tous les postes en NBA après il est pas
si grand bah c'est vrai qu'il y a des
longs bras mais il est pas il fait deux
mètres quoi
la même taille que son coéquipier
Anthony black donc de mettre sans
chaussures de mettre 200 avec un peu
plus de 2 m mais ouais ouais mais
franchement je pense que à terme il peut
il pourra défendre sur tout le monde et
très très bien
psychologiquement qu'est-ce que tu as à
dire sur lui que ce soit interview
comportement sur le terrain etc
il a accepté son rôle il est passé d'un
rôle ou avec une académie il était
Isabelle ballon tout le temps en main il
est passé de ça
incroyable
c'est dingue et il a il a défendu
n'empêche que quand il est rentré il
défendait il faisait ce qu'on lui
demande il a fait ça toute la toute la
saison il a laissé montrer quelques
trucs en attaque donc c'est un type qui
est quand même voilà il a montré qu'il
savait s'adapter à ce qu'on lui
demandait est-ce que c'était la bonne
manière de faire pour progresser je sais
pas je ne sais pas du tout
mais
essayez dans l'interview avec Barlow
c'est de ça dont il parle il parle il
dit que il parle pas de frustration et
dit qu'il a pas su montrer mais qu'il a
plein de choses à montrer donc il va
peut-être lui montrer dans l'exclume
Edge sans son état d'esprit est bon j'ai
l'impression qu'il montre beaucoup de
confiance en lui
voilà
après dans les dans les interviews c'est
un type qui a la qui parle bien je
trouve que c'était assez sympa à
l'écouter il adore le Texas il dit que
c'est là d'où vient tous les meilleurs
joueurs en ce moment de basket
donc je pense qu'il pense à des jeunes
qui arrivent il y a qu'une gamme
voilà il est bon
il a envie de progresser dans son jeu
voilà de quoi il parle ça c'est assez
très original c'est pas très original
exactement mais juste pour revenir sur
sa coordination ce que disait Manu très
vite moi je suis d'accord ça se voit
aussi au niveau offensif ou parfois il a
des mouvements qui sont très fluides et
parfois il va tout droit il fait
n'importe quoi alors est-ce que ça vient
de la frustration est-ce que c'est vrai
que on sent que c'est un type qui est
pas fini c'est il est assez fin en fait
de profil il a des grandes épaules de de
face il est très large en fait il a des
bras immenses ça va se remplir encore et
pour moi pour compléter ce que j'ai Manu
je pense aussi que ça peut devenir un
excellent joueur et beaucoup de fautes
aussi cette année quand même un bémol à
donner quasiment 5 fautes commises par
40 minutes par match
sachant qu'il jouait moins que ça mais
était exclu plusieurs fois alors qu'il
avait c'est ça aussi joué sur son temps
de jeu un petit peu
[Musique]
dernier truc alex je finis là-dessus il
y a quand même il y a Barlow qui lui
demande s'il est pas frustré justement
de pas avoir montré ce qu'il savait
faire en attaque et il dit lui-même
quand même que au début là au début de
la saison il a pas su saisir sa chance
tu vois donc il a une certaine lucidité
qu'on espère salutaire donc est-ce que
vous y croyez Jordan walk est-ce que
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il aura un
deuxième contrat NBA
oui non oui oui
pour Julien
on a envie d'y croire chez envergure
c'est un prospect qui divise mais c'est
un prospect qui a un skill 7 qui demande
à être valorisé
et du coup c'est difficile quand on est
choisi assez loin à la draft d'avoir les
moyens de valoriser ce qu'il sait donc
peut-être que les choses tourneront bien
pour Jordan Wals peut-être qu'il viendra
régaler en Europe en tant que grand
point fort Ward qui peut défendre toutes
les positions c'était notre avis notre
avis surtout nos descriptions de son jeu
au joueur d'art comme ça pour trouver
celle de ses coéquipiers qui sont
prospère qui sont mises en tenue black
mais aussi de tous les autres prospects
qu'on a choisi pour faire des profils
draft sur les plateformes d'écoute sur
Youtube et certaines à l'écrit sur
envergure.co salut tout le monde